what's going on you guys lord addict
here from the iron lords podcast
definitely catch us
every sunday at 1pm we are starting a
new episode
of death door i believe this is episode
four
maybe five not going to don't hold me on
that
so we came in we we we've been chasing
down the wedge we finally got to our
basement we got a new ability with this
little fire spell bomb thing kind of
looks like some kamehameha
stuff and we're gonna go ahead and you
know maybe fight her this episode i
don't know yet though
this thing is mad slow okay you have to
hit it never mind
it's mad slow for a reason
[Music]
so it does seem that uh we are in the
basement that she told us not to go into
so i'm kind of curious what's gonna
happen now
that we're in this basement that she
told us to stay away from
[Music]
all right so it does look like there are
some more
oh gosh that sucks i didn't mean to do
that
[Music]
at least it realized i'm a club
it seems to be i have like infinity
amount of those i don't know
what is that down there
those things are weird what is this
woman doing here man
[Music]
she do it in the in this basement
[Music]
i don't like it creeps me out
i found her oh it's it's it's that dude
upstairs
uh it's what he looks like i warned you
crow yet use preserve i'm not
sure if that's an armor or a stupid no
it's definitely stupid
now if you excuse me i must i must have
some time alone with the superior young
lad here
hopefully i can make it since now please
go away so is that the dude from
upstairs
i don't know
i like the animation of that that was
pretty nice pretty gnarly man that was
pretty good
the inner first furnace there's another
uh
checkpoint to the to the
to the the place where we all are at
i don't know what some of these are kind
of scared to
okay okay
oh it didn't do nothing
so that's their attack as long as i stay
away from little red things you should
be fine
interesting
there's nothing in that green one stupid
pot
i need to stop trying to hit those like
that it's just getting me hurt
[Music]
now what is this
i'm gonna get up there fam i'ma get up
there
i don't appreciate this nonsense you
doing
yeah i'm coming over there
[Music]
oh my god man
yo he just sitting there that just just
casually shoot me over and over again
casually like ain't [ __ ]
i see him i see him
can i open can i can i start that
it would it would not seem so okay uh
yeah i gotta go through this one first
i ain't fighting you guys again you
ain't the enemy
homeboy with the the grenade launcher is
the enemy
i gotta get to him again i feel a
rematch coming
you ain't the enemy either pam i ain't
fighting you either
this dude is the enemy
the only time i could really hit him is
between the smoke stuff
i don't know if the smoke stuff is
hurting me or not
but it's hurting them so it could
definitely hurt me
that's how i beat him he's one of those
idiots where he's going to kill himself
oh snap
oh what you going what you got to say
for yourself
oh he he i i'm about to beat you with
this
hold this fire fireball firebomb jutsu
yeah ah the tank exploded
uh
oh my gosh i guess i'll just wait here
right here for them all to come up
oh too many of them
not dealing with that yeah there's too
many of them how are you doing
[ __ ] to ice hit you once
fireball jitsu
i like the animation for this fireball
you're huge dude
they kind of like it kind of defeats the
purpose if i'm able to just get away
from them
so easy
kind of defeats the purpose just a
little bit
[Music]
is it just shooting one of those every
time
let's see what's what's beyond oh it's a
roly-poly
i seen you guys in a minute how's it
been
it feels like i never see you guys
anymore
[Music]
oh
uh
i don't really want to get
so that's enough i probably could have
dodged all that just got on this thing
[Music]
hold that oh i didn't kill him
[Music]
i ain't doing all that all that's
unnecessary
but i will hit that back at you because
i'm that that's the kind of person i
[Music]
am
oh okay oh
[Music]
um doesn't seem like you can get out of
that
wait wait wait
what's going on like can i shoot
yeah i can okay
oh that's unfortunate
that's unfortunate
know what's up fam the moment i get up
there
it's a rat for you
let's get four
oh yolo
oh my god man how do they expect me
that's a
crazy thing they put down there man
but i respect it i respect it
[Music]
am i going to do their wishes and fight
these things that they want me to fight
probably not am i going to
completely act like these things don't
exist and just run right by them all
probably
come on
i'm not fighting another one it's not
happening
it's a roly-poly we don't gotta fight
none of those though
[Music]
i can totally consume that though
oh my god you guys don't pay me enough
for this
i'm just saying
[Music]
guys don't pay me enough for this
all right so we're back where we were
all right we got three so let's
it looks like they did uh say so we we
do have that
homeboy's real slow right now
we got this one open
all right let's let's go up here and
grab this
let's handle the homeboy the fireball
the fireball jutsu
he's gonna keep trying to ground stomp
us but we ain't that dumb
ah
i'm gonna see if i can get past them all
i see how they roll now oh my god
ah
oh my gosh
that was unfortunate i gotta be real
with you guys that was unfortunate
are you guys going to realize that i
don't
fight things that i don't have to
i think you got like a short short-term
invincibility
that you do got some aim man you can
definitely hit you
not fighting none of you guys
shoot that back
oh snap oh
[Music]
[Music]
the good thing about this is uh we don't
have to worry about this dude on the
right anymore
we already showed him that he can get
dealt with anytime we want to
we're going to pass right by him like
none of that ever happened
[Music]
all right let's put this in there
oh looks like everything's open now
oh my god get out of there
we're not trying to fight all these
extra people man
no
oh i fell off that's coming back i'm
pretty sure that
that comes back yeah i see the shadow
[Music]
i don't have the seed unfortunately
and it looks like this is the boss oh
but
there is a door
and i will go through the door
the door has one through
the laboratory maybe that will generate
like regenerate my health it does
oh here we go the witch is here we're
probably gonna fight her son first i
don't know
we might fight her you little [ __ ]
crows never do what they're told i'm
trying to save lives here don't you
understand death cannot see those who
mask their
life force within an urn i can fool the
grim reapers itself
you and i have something in common
little crow the same employer
but goodness we don't have to find
everything out of that you see
don't worry i'll put your ashes in a
lovely yarn
she's got a yarn on top of her
the witch of earns grandma
oh what you throwing at me
throwing oh
okay throw them both at me grandma
do it grandma
do it grandma
[Music]
oh shoot this
nice little unique boss fight well what
is she
doing grandma what are you doing grandma
what you doing grandma it's hard for me
to trust grandma with these
grandma stop it grandma
[Music]
maybe it's not the greatest move to try
to hit her in that area
she got a little bit of health too oh i
died
wasn't paying attention
i was i was paying attention to her
cracked head
we gonna fire this time again though
there's one
[Music]
there's two
there's three
[Music]
i don't like fighting her hair i like
throwing the fireball
i think it's safer
what is this
oh she she changed it up a little bit
i'm proud
[Music]
changed it up a little bit on
[Music]
what you doing grandma
ow i got hit by that
[Music]
get rid of this one first then this one
then this one then this one
[Music]
oh she was hurt too pretty bad
ah
see trying to to discuss the conference
the the battle with you guys and
staying focused she's she's a pretty
i'm going to say this is a very unique
fight
i need to stop being so what's what i'm
looking for
so extra when i'm fighting
i'm not trying to i mean i guess i could
hit her once or twice doing that
it just doesn't seem like it's worth it
see i got a little bit of damage to her
oh that sucks yeah
oh one two three one two three
one two three one two
got too comfortable hitting the one two
threes
[Music]
three one two three
one two three one two three
miss miss
hold that
[Music]
one two three
one two three one two
oh there's a little fire move now one
two three
one two three one two three
fire ow i missed
one two three one two three one two
three
one two three i'm getting too into it
i'm getting too into it
hold this hold this
one two three one two three
give me yum yum yum yum i want that soul
give it to me
we got one of the souls fellas and
ladies i don't know how many chicks
actually watch these streams
but we got one of them
[Music]
oh that's that's without
him looking like uh whatever he was
looking like
and of course grandma driven by her
material instinct and consumed by her
endeavors to outwit death she filled
her life with a passion of magic
reanimation potions and pots
her journey has concluded that she is
now at peace bow your head and remember
pay your last respects oh so that's the
grave keeper dude that's not the the
grandson
her time in this world is over i suppose
i would never get rid of this part off
her head still
hope she finds peace behind life she can
remember she could finally be united
with
uh grandpa grandpa grandpa
it's the tongue i usually literally had
parts on the brain
seriously though rest in peace grandma
she died at last with a pot on her head
i can respect like
it was a good little boss like that was
a good boss they
they should pat themselves on the on the
back for that that was a good boss
i felt like it was unique um everything
about the boss is good
oh they disappeared then mad fast
all right you guys we're gonna go ahead
in the
episode four or five i can't remember
which one i think it's four
we're gonna go ahead and end it here
appreciate everyone coming through
uh the next episode probably in the next
couple days and until next time
lord addict be sure to watch iop
every sunday at 1 pm lo at the iron
lords podcast with lord cog needle
king david lord sullivan myself and we
discuss
everything in gaming and until next time
this is lord adams i'm outta here peace